[Music]
people know me from what not to wear as
a duo right with Clinton Clinton Kelly
calls out his former co-host Stacy
London for blocking him on social media
why would you want to do that
the former what not to wear co-host
appears to be in a one-sided fashion
feud on Wednesday Clinton took to
Twitter with a screenshot showing he was
blocked by 48 year old Stacy he
captioned the posts alrighty then it's a
second uh yeah that is an unacceptable
response Clinton's followers were
seemingly in shock but he quickly
responded to the messages insisting this
isn't a new issue the TV personality
wrote the T is old and I never spilled
tea unless I'm shook which I'm not thank
you for telling us bogarting new another
user pointed out that Clinton doesn't
follow Stacy on Twitter either you want
to start attacking me we can go there
his response quote someone tagged us in
the same tweet
I don't need attention I thought it was
hilarious
yeah it's well explained
[Music]
you